i think the world will absolutely make
them pay a price you can see it
every place i go every foreign minister
that i talk to
they recognize what what china has done
to the world
secretary of state mike pompeo saying he
believes the world will hold
china accountable for the coronavirus
pandemic
it's just the latest escalation in a
rapid decline in relations with that
communist country
general jack keane is a retired four
star general chairman of the institute
for the study of war and a fox news
senior strategic analyst jack good to
see you this morning
what what price might china pay there is
talk that the white house may implement
some
travel restrictions on members of the
chinese communist party but that
seems to also be tied to china's
treatment of the uyghurs and what's
going on in hong kong and not just
coronavirus so
what what price might be exactly from
china over this whole thing
well certainly i think there's going to
be some retribution for the pandemic
the fact that the outcry around the
world certainly is
what we have all seen the deception
about the origins of the
of the of the pandemic but most
significantly
is he permitted it to be spread once he
knew he had human human transfer around
the world i
i absolutely believe that was a
conscious move on president xi's part
he knew his economy was going to be
affected and he wanted particularly
western economies to be affected as well
and significantly the united states and
of course he has achieved that
so the nations of the world are repulsed
by that
giving the horror of the lost loss of
life and the destruction
of world economies so retribution is
there sanctions are there but mostly
what is really changing here john is
there's a broad coalition developing in
the world
that is becoming anti-china and it's
being led by the united states
and it gives the united states a huge
strategic opportunity with our
partners and allies to develop a grand
strategy
to confront china and to contain their
malign and aggressive behavior
it's not just about the pandemic but
that certainly is the catalyst
for bringing this coalition together
that secretary pompeo was talking about
in your introduction
so on the in on this idea general about
how china is viewed around the world
it looks like they're going to enter
into a major trade deal
with iran to guarantee some 25 years of
discounted oil for china
of course iran isn't exactly the sort of
player that we want to be
doing any kind of business with but the
uk who we do do a lot of business with
just said that it's not going to use any
huawei products in the core of its 5g
system so that is really shutting out
china
you know at least in the uk there yeah
this is very frustrating to
to china because they they really wanted
to
run the world table in terms of owning
5g
which means actually owning most of the
telecom systems in the world most of the
servers
most of the personal data in the world
and it would be
absolutely destructive to us we've
already seen what
massive cyber espionage has done to the
united states in terms of intellectual
property
and also to our allies and what massive
disinformation campaigns
that the prc has conducted as well and
likely these countries would not be
pulling away from
huawei uh running 5g for them
if it was not for this malign and
aggressive behavior of president xi
dealing with the pandemic and i believe
this john i believe history will show us
that president g has been the most
aggressive the most ambitious
and the most malign leaders from mouse
of tongue and
i think we're going to see that he
overreached he put he put
he put the ccp on a fast track to
achieve
china's dream which is what it's
domination control of the asia pacific
and replacing the united states
as the world's global leader he thought
that he could achieve that uh within the
next five or six years and this is
blowing up in his face as a result of
his aggressive behavior
yeah now the united states saying that
it will stand with people who feel that
their sovereignty has been nations at
least who whose sovereignty
has been affronted by china nations like
vietnam
the philippines malaysia and others
general jack keane
always good to see you thanks so much
for joining us on this thursday morning
yeah great talking to you john